- I don't know if we're
ready to pull this up,
but I wanna pull it up
cause it's my favorite thing
about this interview is
you dancing on TikTok, you're a hit.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know if you know,
- I like to dance, because I'm an idiot.
- Are you serious? No, I am not kidding.
- I was kicking my stupid
- I'm not even being funny right now.
- Was it to Miley flowers?
- Yeah to flowers.
- I know it. I saw it.
- Let's see it. Let's show it.
- Okay, here we go.
♪ I can buy myself flowers, ♪
♪ Write my name in the sand, ♪
♪ Talk to myself for hours, ♪
♪ Say things you don't understand, ♪
♪ I can take myself dancing, ♪
- I love it, you're like, not about it.
It's literally like,
I didn't think I could love you more.
And I watched this and I was like
it's the best part is
you're like, you're like
this looks like a good spot.
- And then you go for it,
and then you're like, maybe this spot.
And it's I, that's
literally me at my house.
I love dancing.
I, I own it all the time on this show.
When I'm home alone, I dance in my house
and I think even in front of my kids.
They think I'm nuts, but I love dancing.
It looks like you feel
good when you do it.
- I I had a fun time, but I'm a moron.
- No, you're not.
- I'm no, I don't call that being a moron.
I call that feeling free
and like vulnerable and like awesome.
- It was fun.
Yeah. I love that video.
I was like, we're showing it.
So
- And her whole Instagram
feed, it takes her hours.
It's, a huge feed,
- It's brilliant.
- and all of it is,
she has one part that's doors.
It's just doors.
- All about doors.
- Doors. You don't wanna
miss out on the doors.
- I'm I'm not kidding.
You are blowing, I don't even know
if you know this, but you have like
blown up on TikTok. Like literally
- I have? I had no idea. I What is TikTok?
I don't even know.
- Exactly. I'm 40. I know, I get it.
But like you are like, it's it's insane.
Everybody's like, did you see the video?
And I'm like, I did. It's incredible.
I and you, I think it's,
and first of all, I love doors.
What are they like different
doors all over the world.
- Yeah. I like the doors. Yes, of course.
- Oh, I thought you meant like actual
- No doors.
- Yeah. I used to do that in Spain.
When I walked in Spain
I used to take pictures
cause all the doors in architecture.
- Cause they're amazing.
- They're amazing.
- That's right.
Yeah. And I'm obsessed with them.
- I'm right Sophie.
- We have so much in common and wine.